i think that men are more likely to get  into physical fights and women are more  likely to destroy your life by forming  little posses and being like yeah this  person slept with that person even if  you didn't like it gets mean and dark  and can like destroy you he's got to be  above it i think you haven't been a high  school girl i mean i haven't but here's  what i would explain to my friends right  there were people who would fart in  class and then turn blush red and  everyone started laughing at them and  pointing like hey you're far they'd be  like shut up no i didn't shut up and  then there were the other people more  like me who would hey hey ian  and laugh and ever be like oh you're a  jerk i'm like i don't care i'd do  whatever i want you can't make fun  because i don't care about what you  think